if you love better call solved here are
5 other shows totally worth checking out
on this week's binge guide it's all good
man hey gang marquel is here coming to
you from my own house or my mom's garage
with the 5th straight certified fresh'
season a better call Saul coming to a
close this the prequel series Breaking
Bad which you should probably go back
and watch Breaking Bad again too
anyway better call Saul it just keeps
getting better and better so we decided
to put together a guide for what you can
check out next starting with our
certified fresh pick justified with a
sixth season tomato meter average of 97%
this drama starts Timothy all the fans
as a maverick us Marshall and Kentucky
who enforces the law is way much like a
certain New Mexico lawyer from Federer
called salted fans well critics
continually gave justified high praise
in part because it's crisp storytelling
and colorful characters who never take
themselves too seriously and with just
over fifty seven hours of binge time
this one will give you a newfound
respect for US marshals and just like
teach us something about certain parts
of the Bluegrass State you never knew
existed up next is our brand new pic and
that's Ozark with its third and highest
rated season recently released on
Netflix if you love the federal costs
all element of a likeable leading man
who falls deeper and deeper in with a
dangerous drug cartel this is the show
for you with strong performances from
Jason Bateman Laura Linney and Julia
Garner among others critics call this
one engaging and entertaining with a
satisfying complex plot with 3 10
episode seasons under its belt this will
take you about 28 hours to get through
and it might make you think twice about
vacationing in the Ozarks slicing its
way next onto this list is our throwback
pin and that is Dexter this Showtime
series the ran from 2006 to 2013 stars
Michael see all that the forensic expert
living a double life as a vigilante
serial killer murdering only bad people
who have escaped justice fans a better
call Saul will enjoy rooting for this
antihero who tries to do good by doing
bad in what critics have called a
compelling elegantly crafted horror
drama
with eight seasons and a total watch
time of just under eighty five hours
binging this one will save you some time
but pro tip if you skip the last season
you'll probably have a better taste in
your mouth when it's all said and done
next is our upcoming pick Fargo with the
new season due out later this year this
anthology series inspired by the 1996
Coen Brothers films has already turned
in three certified fresh' seasons each
featuring a new batch of fascinating
characters and great acting that sounds
familiar better call saul fans with
stars like Billy Bob Thornton Kirsten
John's Hume aggregor and soon Chris Rock
critics have enjoyed the show's sly wit
and off-kilter Sensibility paired with
cheeky cynicism and just a touch of the
absurd what more do you need
binging this will take you twenty six
and a half hours and you just might
develop a fun new accent by the time
you're done with it
and finally for our editor's pick we are
recommending the Showtime series ray
Donovan this one follows a professional
fixer for the rich and famous in Los
Angeles who is great and making people's
problems disappear except for those
created by his own family critics have
hailed this series for the transfixing
performances by its two leads we have
Schreiber and John Boyer who anchor a
group of deeply flawed characters you
either love or love to hate somewhere to
the characters found in better call Saul
this show was cancelled after seven
seasons which will take you about 80
hours to get through but keep an eye out
for a possible eighth season after fans
recently started a change.org petition
to save the show okay hopefully this
will help guide you through your next
few big sessions
be sure to check back for more
recommendations and ideas based around
the other shows you love right here on
the right Tomatoes binge guy
[Music]